[Musique]
qui dit noël dit cadeau aurélie on va se
replonger en enfance avec vous c'est une
des grandes tendances de cette année les
jouets rétro vintage qui reviennent à la
mode
et oui noël 2018 ne sera pas uniquement
high tech puisque selon une étude
opinionway
un français sur deux serait nostalgique
de ces jouets d'enfance et j'imagine que
c'est le cas également sur ce plateau
on va faire un petit tour de table
justement wilfrid je commence par vous
dans la voile assez bon par mois votre
jouet préféré quand vous étiez en jouets
préférés
c'est mon jouet préféré je ne sais pas
les voitures télécommandées peut-être ce
genre de choses là voilà manon j'ai
beaucoup joué avec les barbie à la
presse dans les clichés pour l'instant
vous voyez pas que j'étais très
playmobil un métier pas par bin non
conditionnel de barbie au ciel
s'assombrit charge des voix c'était les
genoux et reste dans les prés noël jour
emmanuel moire c'est plutôt les jeux de
construction les maisons en bois on
prévoyait l'emplacement de la femme est
remplacement de la porte
la cheminée faille pas l'oublier capela
les exactement voilà des bouquets à gori
mois des pokémon power rangers vous
apprécierez l'âge de chacune des
personnes autour de la table en fonction
de ce jouet en tout cas tout s'est joué
dans les airs on les retrouve un dans
les rayons à des anciennes spécialisés
des jouets qui ont été réédités pour
certains qui ont eu un petit coup de
jeune on est allé vérifier ça à
rambouillet on va retrouver des
reproductions de ces mêmes produits qui
n'existaient plus ces dernières années
qui sont ressortis ces derniers temps
pour justement satisfaire là on est plus
sur une demande en fait des parents le
magnétophone à cassette donc là c'est la
fidèle reproduction
de la version en 2018 donc ya pas de mp3
ça reste toujours la petite cassette
audio également le téléphone classique a
attiré donc là c'est pas le smartphone
vous êtes vraiment sûr le téléphone très
classique qui existait dans les années
80 également vous allez avoir le kiki de
tous les kikis donc en fait il a eu des
renommées monchy schiste le nom original
et ça c'est pareil c'est une tendance
qui joue ça joue beaucoup sur la
nostalgie
on a évidemment voilà renvoie les
caméras j'imagine la slovaquie
génération s'attarder titi buengo
voilà ses démons chichi puisque en fait
le nom a changé en 2013 suite au rachat
de la marque
on remercie d'ailleurs mélanie qui nous
a prêté son kiki voilà tarifs bien dire
mon chichi en fait aujourd'hui ça passe
mais qui était d'ailleurs voir et nous
avons alors dans les rayons on a pu voir
également plusieurs d'anciens jouets
jeux fisher price en fait qui était très
populaire dans les années 60 70
ils ont été donc réédité mais en fait
ils sont distribués par une entreprise
qui est bien connu sur le territoire
saint quentin en yvelines
l'entreprise asmodée alors j'ai avec moi
sur ce plateau notamment une réduction
du jeu le fermier a dit il avait été
lancée en 1965 en fait c'était à
l'époque le tout premier jouer je
voudrais passer où l'on pouvait en fait
on tente des différents sons inde
animaux on a juste à aller déjà attiré
en fait faut juste irez vous avez vous
avez normalement sur le côté oui j'avais
une fois dessus voilà papa fonctionner
un jouet
c'est bien voilà et alors c'est dessiner
évidemment mieux de toutes les missions
un public assez jeune à partir de 18
mois c'est ça vaut à peu près 30 euros
il ya également cette télévision
musicale c'était la première donc et qui
est sorti en 1966 était pour les enfants
de 12 mois et plus
il ya des comptines ce qu'il ya c'est
que si je mets le avec lui on va voir
plein de sons pourquoi les joueurs
qu'ils soient rue pour leur tranquillité
des parents les tablettes c'est beaucoup
plus calme c'était donc la première télé
musicales dont qui est sorti en 1966 et
puis troisième objets vintage également
streep est distribué par asmodée l
appareil photo à fisher price donc qui
est sorti en 1968 il ya des disques à
insérer on peut donc voir des histoires
de boucle d'or notamment
voilà donc c'est un design vraiment
vintage vintage y arrive ça peut
paraître assez désuet mais en fait c'est
vraiment une vraie demande un
aujourd'hui une vraie demande évidemment
des parents puisque à cette notion de
transmission qui est important pour pour
les parents et puis en fait la
conclusion c'est que même si on prend de
l'âge
on reste tous deux très grands enfants
il ya des choix que vous avez eu les uns
les autres
non non en tant qu'ancien alors patrick
jacq de disney qui est donc tu fais
partie de la rédaction m'a dit que voilà
il avait connu on fait un petit plomb et
pourquoi trier
lyon voilà but local voilà voilà mais
c'est plutôt voilà nos parents oui j'ai
déjà grand pour moi ça va faire deux
sets et les enfants comment alors les
enfants véritablement arrive à se
prendre à ce genre de jouer malgré la
concurrence des télécentres parce que
c'est quand même plus un désir des
parents fait le voilà d'avoir le plaisir
de revoir les jouets de leur enfance
[Musique]